Welcome students back to the
Pharmacology of
Immunosuppressant Drugs.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
This lecture will
describe the pharmacology
of the immunosuppressive
therapies used for
maintaining prophylaxis
of acute rejection.
Please contact me if
you'd like a chat.
and the learning objectives
are what you always need
to know for pharmacology
the pharmacokinetics
mechanisms of action toxicities
interactions and again i
challenge you to make
yourself some sort of a figure
or map that integrates the
pharmacology so that you
can see the big picture and
how everything fits into
the big picture and fits
together with each other.
Here are the preparation
materials, links,
key points, this is more
or less the overview,
and each of the drugs
that we'll talk about.
Not too many drugs to
memorize in this group.
And considering
there are hundreds of
immunosuppressants
available now, it's a huge
industry, projected to
be $80 billion by 2030.
We'll begin with our calcinarin
inhibitors. These are
absolutely the mainstay of
maintenance immunotherapy.
Two of them, cyclosporine
and tacrolimus,
however you like
to pronounce it.
Cyclosporine was first. First,
it really was instrumental
in the success
of kidney transplantation
back in the day.
Tacrolimus came along
later and has become
the preferred drug
because of efficacy,
and we'll see the total
reasons in a minute or so.
They have very similar
pharmacokinetic
properties. oral.
Both have IVs available,
variable absorption,
other formulations,
highly bound to
plasma proteins,
substrates of CYP3A4
and p-glycoprotein,
biliary and *****
excretion, and
long half-life,
variable and long.
Both need to be monitored.
Plasma concentrations need
to be monitored to make
sure these drugs are within
the therapeutic range,
which makes sense because of
the variability in the
absorption, the potential for
drug interactions, numerous
patient factors as well.
And they have narrow
therapeutic windows. Here's
the mechanism. Here is our
T-cell receptor complex.
You'll see T-cell receptor
and CD3 on here. The
pathway, the T-cell receptor
pathway, very simplified.
And what we're going
to be looking at
in this pathway is
here at calcineurin.
Both of them, both of these
drugs bind to something
called an immunophylline,
but not the same one.
Cyclosporine will
bind cyclophiline.
Tachrolimus will bind FKBP.
FKBB12 to be exact.
FKBP is enough to know.
That forms a complex. So
here we have our sarcophalin
and our drug and that will
complex with calcineurin.
So we have that three-way
complex one, two, three.
That will inhibit
the activity of
calcineurin which is
to dephosphorylate
nuclear factor of
activated T cells.
When it's phosphorylated, it is
inactive. So by
removing that phosphate,
it becomes active. This
is a cytosolic form of it.
Moves into the
nucleus. Here we see
it dimerizing with
the nuclear form.
And that will cause
gene transcription
and particularly
IL-2, but other
cytokines as well.
So just to recap,
three-way complex blocks
dephosphorylation
of calcineurin,
which blocks the actions
of nuclear factor of
activated T cells.
Therefore, that blocks the
synthesis and release
of IL-2 and other
cytokines, so this downstream
pathway is blocked.
That's it.
They are highly efficacious
immunosuppressive
drugs in routine
use. Prophylaxis
of solid organ
allograft rejection.
Treatment of GBHD after
hematopoietic stem cell
transplantation. Auto-immune
inflammatory disorder,
cyclosporine is an
ophthalmic for uveitis.
Tacrolimus can be
used topically for
atopic dermatitis
and psoriasis, and
these are T-cell
-related inflammations.
Now, here's the
reason why tacrolimus
is preferred. Compared
to cyclosporine,
tacrolimus is associated
with decreased
acute rejection rates,
so better efficacy.
It is better tolerated.
Importantly, it does
not lower mycophenolate
levels. We'll be
seeing this one next.
This mycophenolate
mofetil is nearly always
used in combination
with these drugs.
So it's really
important that the drugs
don't affect the levels
of mycophenolate.
And the costs are
about the same.
So that's like a
neutral factor.
So to recap,
better efficacy,
decreased acute rejection,
does not affect
mycophenolate levels,
better tolerated, and
the costs are similar.
Nephrotoxicity. Well,
there are a bunch of them.
Nephrotoxicity. Oh gosh,
didn't I say this is used
for renal transplant and yet
it causes nephrotoxicity?
Apparently, it causes
vasoconstrictor effects
on the afferent renal
arteriole and that's
going to reduce blood
flow to the kidney.
Interstitial fibrosis.
Nephrotoxicity is common in all
transplant patients,
both renal and non
-renal transplant,
kidney transplant.
So patients need to
be monitored for this.
And nephrotoxicity is a
common reason why a patient
may need to be switched off
of a calcineurin inhibitor.
So what else?
Hypertension, that's
manageable. Here are
the mechanisms. renal
vasoconstriction,
sodium retention.
Neurotoxicity.
Patients frequently
have this fine tremor.
Headache, insomnia.
Patients need to
be informed about
that. And there are
some other things
that could happen.
Elevated serum potassium
related to the kidney
adverse effects again.
Tubular insensitivity to
aldosterone, which is a
mineralocorticoid, which
actually comes from the
adrenal cortex and is
responsible for a number
of functions, including
potassium excretion,
secretion. So hyperkalemia
can come because of
the reduced function of
aldosterone on the
kidney tubules, liver,
endocrine hyperglycemia,
GI effects, diarrhea,
nausea, vomiting, and of
course infection, potential
for malignancy. That's
why we like to lower the
dose as much as possible.
Now cyclosporine's
got some extras
involved, gingival
hyperplasia, hirsutism.
You may remember I
mentioned with regard to
hyperglycemia that the
glucocorticoids can also
cause hyperglycemia and
it's the initial therapy
includes the calcineurin
inhibitor, the
mycophenolate mofetil
usually, and the prednisone.
My potential for drug
interactions, I don't even
have to tell you that
now, it just comes second
nature to you, knowing
that it is CYP3A4
substrate and P-glycoprotein
substrate. So anti
-inducers or inhibitors
are going to affect the
blood levels of cyclosporine
and of tacrolimus.
Cyclosporine does reduce
mycophenolate serum
concentrations.
Mycophenolic acid,
mycophenolate, is the
active form of the
drug that's given.
How? Well, the proposed
mechanism, which seems to
be most likely, is blocking
an efflux transporter in
the liver. This efflux
transporter is called MRP2.
And blocking this prevents
biliary excretion of
the active compound,
mycophenolic acid. Why does
this matter? Because
mycophenolic acid undergoes
enterohepatic circulation,
which then increases
serum concentrations.
And if we block this,
it gets excreted.
So it lowers the
concentrations. And it
actually has quite a
significant effect on the
concentrations of
mycophenolate and mofetil.
Other drugs that
cause toxicities,
same toxicities,
nephrotoxicity,
neurotoxicity,
hyperkalemia, hypertension,
diabetes, and on and on.
These two drugs are
not used together.
Number one, they interfere
with the mechanisms of
each other, but importantly,
they increase the
risk of toxicities. They
have the same toxicities.
So I'm going back to
remind you of our strong
inducers yet again. They
come up over and over,
carbamazepine, phenobarbital
or all barbiturates
phenytoin rifampin which
is an antibiotic st john's
wort which is over the
counter and there's a few
others strong inhibitors
reminding you of those of
which there are many
many many many cyp3a4 and
p glycoprotein inhibitors
top of the list are
ritonavir and other protease
inhibitors. We'll get to
that in one of the lectures
here in this block.
Cubicostats, same
thing, we'll get to
it. Both of these
are potent, potent
CYP3A4 inhibitors.
Iftraconazole, we'll
get to that one too.
Clarithromycin,
remember this
macrolide antibiotic,
grapefruit juice, and so on.
Calcineurin inhibitors have
a narrow therapeutic window.
So any inhibition or
induction of their
metabolism can change
their blood levels.
inhibition can increase the
risk of toxicity induction
can decrease efficacy
decrease blood levels decrease
therapeutic effect what
do we worry about there
transplantation rejection
serious serious serious
let's look at the
anti-metabolites Now,
mycophenolate mofetil, I
referred to earlier, azathioprine
is something we've
seen with the DMARDS.
Pharmacokinetics,
beginning with
mycophenolate mofetil,
which is the preferred
drug by most
transplant centers.
it is a pro-drug and this
is the active mycophenolic
acid mycophenolate drug
is available oral or iv
rapidly mmf is rapidly complete
and completely converted
to 2-microfenolic acid
in the liver, so we see a
really good bioavailability.
That 94% is of the IV,
really good.
Enterohepatic circulation
I referred to earlier.
Now the MPA, the active,
is glucuronidated,
and that gets excreted in the
urine, and it's got
a decent half-life.
prophylaxis of organ rejection
obviously and here's
our combination
mmf has superior efficacy
and a better side effect
profile than azathioprine
which is why it is preferred
by many transplant centers
it's also used for gbhd
and it's got some uses and
autoimmune disease as well.
How does it work?
It is a potent selective
uncompetitive reversible
inosine monophosphate
dehydrogenase inhibition.
By blocking this
enzyme that inhibits
guanosine nucleotide
synthesis which
is important in the
de novo pathway,
de novo purine
synthesis pathway,
which means they have to,
I can't speak, it's important
in making new guanosine
nucleotides. Many, many
cell types will just reuse
what they have. And that's
through the actions of
hypoxanthine guanine
phosphoribosyl transferase, HGPRT.
But T and B cells
make their own new.
They're very
active, as you know,
and they need these purines.
So by blocking IMPDH, that's
going to suppress function.
Prevent the DNA synthesis.
which naturally
prevents function,
proliferation and function.
Bone marrow
suppression, anemia,
leukopenia are most
frequently seen.
Persistent diarrhea, nausea,
vomiting, dose-related again.
Again, risk of serious
toxicity, which is
a class effect of
immunosuppressants.
Infection, malignancy,
avoid impregnancy,
keratogenic.
Do not use impregnancy.
Okay, drug interactions.
Other immunosuppressants.
so of course it's
being used in this
three drug combination
but it should not be used with
additional immunosuppressants
drugs that suppress bone marrow
cyclosporine because of
reduced levels of mycophenolic
acid that is not an
absolute contraindication
but cyclosporine is avoided
in preference of tacrolimus.
Cholestyramine, which is
a bile acid sequestrant
that stays in the gut and
that will chelate the drug
and carry it right on out.
It doesn't get absorbed.
We said these drugs
can cause nausea
and yet we should not be
giving an antacid at the
same time because that
can reduce the absorption.
So azathioprine now,
oral prodrug, it's
converted to 6
-mercaptopurine,
rapid conversion,
and 6-mercaptopurine is
metabolized to inactive
metabolites by xanthine
oxidase and thiopurine methyl
transferase. We see that
here on this little figure.
and the metabolites
are excreted in the
urine. Half-life of
the 6-MP is about an
hour, but the biologic
half-life is longer.
We need to remember our
patients who may have
deficient TPMT activity
because they are certainly at
increased risk for life
-threatening myelosuppression
as a greater amount of
the azathioprine in a dose
will be shifted to the
toxic nucleotide pathway.
Prophylaxis of acute
allograft rejection,
so it's an anti
-metabolite that would
be used with a
calcineurin inhibitor and
a glucocorticoid
as initial therapy.
And it's also used in anti
-inflammatory and
autoimmune diseases.
Here's the mechanism.
The 6-MP is converted to
thioenosine monophosphate,
which is, in turn, converted
to the toxic nucleotides,
toxic guanine nucleotides,
which are incorporated
into the DNA in proliferating
cells, T and B cells.
This will induce strand
breaks and lead to cell death.
Toxicity is bone
marrow suppression
with profound leukopenia.
Hepatotoxicity with
high doses, especially
patients who have
hepatic dysfunction.
GI effects,
immunosuppressant effects.
In pregnancy, azathioprine
has actually been
used safely.
Azathioprine tends to be
fairly well tolerated.
Most of the important
adverse effects occur
with the higher doses.
Drug interaction xanthine
oxidase inhibitors will
inhibit the conversion
of 6-mercaptopurine to
the inactive thioeuric
acid. Thus, shifting the 6
-mercaptopurine to the
HGPRT pathway, increasing
the risk of azathioprine
toxicity. I used AZA
through here instead of
6-MP to drive home that
we're talking about
azathioprine. But, of course,
it's the 6-MP that is
going through the pathway.
And don't forget,
pharmacogenomics. Imagine
if an individual has
deficient TPMT and is
also taking a xanthine
oxidase inhibitor. That
would be really dangerous.
Now moving on to our selective
T-cell co-stimulation
blocker. This is
Balotacept. This is a
second generation CTLA4
-IgG fusion protein. The
first one that we saw was
abatacept or abatacept.
We get evolution of
pronunciations over time.
Balatacept has a much
stronger affinity
for the target than
does abatacept. And
this is FDA approved
for transplantation.
Here we have our antigen
-presenting cell. Here we have
our MHC, our generic MHC
here, our T-cell receptor.
There would be a CD4, CD8 here,
stimulator. This is the
CD8086 on the antigen
-presenting cell, also
called B7, 1 and 2.
the co-stimulation action
is between the CD8 and this.
So, if we have a drug with
CTLA-4 on it, as melitacept,
The CTLA-4 will get to
the CD80-86 and has higher
affinity than the CD28 and
prevent this interaction.
So preventing the co
-stimulatory effect prevents the
activation action, downstream
actions of the T-cell.
It's used for maintenance
therapy for prophylaxis
of acute organ rejection
in kidney transplant
patients who are
seropositive for Epstein-Barr
virus. This is the patient
population in clinical
trials, and this is how
it got its FDA approval.
Recall that patients
who are seropositive
for EBV have been
infected with Epstein
-Barr virus at some
point in their life.
that means they have
developed antibodies immunity
against the ebv so that if
their graft is has ebv in it
the patient will already have
the the antibodies to the
ebv now if A patient is
seronegative for Epstein-Barr
virus, given this maintenance
immunotherapy, and the
graft has EBV in it, then
the patient can develop post
-transplant lymphoproliferative
disorder. It's a much
higher potential, higher
risk in patients who are EBV
negative. So that's how
Balotacept got its FDA approval.
Balotacept should not be
given to EBV seronegative
patients or unknown
status because of the
increased risk of PTLD in
this patient population.
Now the mTOR inhibitors.
I put a star on
sirolimus. Everolimus
is also used in cancer
and has found indications
in transplantation.
However, they are
basically the same.
So knowing one,
you'll know the other.
mTOR stands for mammalian
target of rapamycin.
And sirolimus was
originally called rapamycin.
hence the name of the protein,
and now the drug is
called Sirolimus.
Oral, I put some
other uses down there,
but it's oral for
transplantation.
High plasma protein binding,
P-glycoprotein substrate,
CYP3A4 substrate,
***** excretion,
and a long half-life.
As with so many of these
drugs, the serum levels
need to be monitored.
Mechanism.
Oh,
well, Sirolimus
binds to FKBP also.
The same FKBP12 that
Tacrolimus binds to.
But it's in a different
location in the pathways.
So this is, mTOR is in a
cytokine pathway.
It is a kinase.
We get the three-way complex
form, drug FKBP and the
mTOR complex that inhibits
mTOR activity, which in
turn prevents the progression
of the cell cycle to
G1S phase, and that causes
cell cycle arrest, which
inhibits cell survival,
growth, and proliferation.
Simple idea.
alternative for kidney
transplant rejection prophylaxis
that's what it got its
FDA approval for an organ
transplantation it's
also used and other organ
transplantation please note
that the safety and efficacy and
liver transplantation lung
lung transplantation have
not been established, and
the use is not recommended.
It can also be used for GVHD.
And here are non-transplant
uses, which I'm not
asking you to remember.
You don't have to
remember those for now.
They're here for context.
Toxicities. Well,
profound myelosuppression.
With suppression of
platelets, common. And also
anemia, leukopenia,
impaired wound healing,
wound dehiscence. That
means the wound comes
apart. The surgical
anastomosis can pull apart if
the sirolimus is given
before the wound heals.
And that's because sirolimus
has anti-angiogenesis effects.
high cholesterol elevated
cholesterol in the
blood elevated triglycerides
in the blood various
edema conditions
interstitial lung disease
gut and nervous
system and joint
pain and sores in
the mouth and acne.
Infection risk, naturally,
hypersensitivity
reactions, of course.
Cyclosporine or
tacrolimus together
with sirolimus
should be avoided.
The combination increases
the risk of nephrotoxicity,
increases the risk
of various adverse
drug events,
including mortality,
Cyclosporine, together
with it, may increase
the risk of something
called hemolytic
uremic syndrome, which
is life-threatening.
Sirolimus, together with
tacrolimus, decreases
tacrolimus' blood
levels considerably.
And, of course, drugs
that are CYP3A4 and
P-glycoprotein inducers
and inhibitors.
so in summary
this is our t-cell pathways
with the various drugs on
here to give you a picture
and i invite you to draw
your own pictures in a way
that has meaning for you
maintenance
immunosuppressive agents are
intended to provide
adequate immunosuppression
to prevent allograft
rejection, and they are
dosed in a way to
minimize infection,
malignancy, and drug
-related adverse effect risk.
The regimens typically
include two to four
drugs. The initial
maintenance immunosuppression
in most transplant
centers consists of the
tacrolimus, mycophenylate,
mofetil, and prednisone,
which I've indicated
here by their classes.
The calcineur inhibitors
inhibit the actions
of nuclear factor of
activated T-cells,
which inhibits the
synthesis, transcription,
and production of
cytokines, such as IL-2.
Cyclosporin binds to the
immunophyllin
called ciclofilin.
Tachrolimus binds to the
immunophyllin called FKBP-12.
Three-way complex inhibits
the activity of calcineurin.
So N-fat is not
dephosphorylated,
does not translocate
to the nucleus.
Cyclosporine and
tacrolimus are substrates
of CYP3A family,
P-glycoprotein.
substantial inter
-individual variation
between oral absorption
and metabolism of these
drugs, so drug
monitoring is essential.
Calcineurin inhibitors
are associated
with quite an array
of toxicities.
Nephrotoxicity is a very
important one, generally
at the top of the list.
Infection is possible.
Cyclosporine can cause
gingival hyperplasia and
hirsutism, which is not
seen with tacrolimus.
Mycophenylate and mofetil
and azathioprine are anti
-metabolites, so they block
lymphocyte proliferation
by inhibiting purine
synthesis and DNA synthesis.
Mycophenylate mofetil's
active metabolite is
called mycophenolic
acid. It is a potent,
reversible, non-competitive
inhibitor of IMPDH,
inocene monophosphate
dehydrogenase, which
blocks the de novo
formation of guanosine
monophosphate, blocking T
and B cell proliferation.
Azathioprine is a pro
-drug converted to 6
-mercaptopurine and then
to cytotoxic 6-thioguanine
nucleotides, which
are incorporated
into the DNA strand,
causing strand breakage.
They are adjuncts with
calcineurin inhibitors,
with or without glucocorticoid.
As I said originally,
they start with this
three-drug combination
and gradually reduce the
doses and hopefully at
some point are able to
remove the glucocorticoid.
MMF has largely replaced
azathioprine due
to its improved safety
and efficacy profile.
Belatacept is a recombinant
fusion protein of CTLA
-4 co-stimulation blocker
which prevents the co
-stimulation action of CD28 on
T cells binding to the CD8086
on APCs, therefore
inhibiting T-cell activation.
It is intended as a
substitute for calcineurin
inhibitors to avoid the
long-term nephrotoxicity,
cardiovascular, and
metabolic complications
seen with cyclosporine
and tachlorolimus.
It increases the risk of
PTLD and is contraindicated
in individuals who are
seronegative for Epstein
-Barr virus. mTOR inhibitors,
sirolimus, and avirolimus
bind FKBP12, and then
complex with mTOR, which
inhibits that whole
cytokine signaling pathway,
causing cell cycle
arrest in the G1 phase.
It prevents G1 progression
to the S phase.
And that inhibits T
cell proliferation and
everything else that
goes on in that pathway.
They are frequently
used in multi-drug
regimens to allow
reduction of calcineurin
inhibitors. mTOR inhibitors
are associated with
impaired wound healing,
wound dehiscence,
leukopenia,
saromocytopenia, anemia,
hypercholesterolemia,
hypertriglyceridemia,
diarrhea, peripheral
edema, and so on.
Substrates of CYP3A4P
glycoprotein, low
bioavailability, extensive
hepatic metabolism,
high potential for
drug interactions.
And here is a chart kind
of summarizing everything.
And I thank you for
listening to this lecture.